[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast it's
about death sometimes and which to your
favorite people at all dang world Hank
John Green answered progressions give
you to this advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hey John how you doing you
cutie face well that's a first to be
honest with you I'm shaking like a dove
giving birth because I have just done my
first interview for Turtles all go down
like with a journalist who'd read the
book and I mean ha I am actually shaking
Hank I it's so stressful because you
don't want to say anything stupid and
that of course dramatically increases
the chances of saying something stupid
if the whole time you're thinking don't
say anything stupid don't say any what
are you gonna do of course you're gonna
say something stupid so I don't know
what I said but now I'm like running it
all back in my mind trying to think
about did I say anything stupid like you
should just like walk into the interview
and start out with something stupid like
just start out real dumb and then that's
that is not a good strategy and then
it's like like you're like well I don't
have to worry about saying anything
stupid cuz they did that already have
you seen what the Internet does to
people who say something stupid oh I see
what you mean by stupid I have now I
have a different I have a different
conception of of the same educated Lee
in which case I'm now shaking like a
dove giving birth for you I I don't
really understand the idea of a dove
giving birth but I imagine anything
giving birth you got a quiver a little
bit now that I think about it doves
don't really give birth so much as they
give eggs
you know John there's a book that I read
to Orin frequently it's called when
animals kiss if animals kissed like we
kiss goodnight and others there's a line
in it that says mama Python and
hatchling would kiss waggling round
twirling and twisting like rope loosely
wound and that upsets me John because
pythons
live birth and don't have hatchlings so
that book could just go right in the
fires of history for all I care it's
scientifically inaccurate the breaking
news Hank green advocates book burning
in recent podcast pro book burner Hank
green has just said that he wants to
burn a book for one small error I man
killed my dove quivering his begun
breaking news Hank green heating oven to
Fahrenheit 451 to burn local book local
book welcome [ __ ] in fear for his life
from Hank green alright I don't know I
don't have a short poem for you today I
do have a book of short poem
recommendations it's it's counting
descent by Clint Hill Smith it has
really it's it's shaken me up in the
best way
or possibly shook me up in the best way
I don't have a very good grammar but I
do have this question from Clara not
Clara or she wrote that her name is
pronounced like clay - raw not clad a
shrub I actually don't find not helpful
Clara it's Clara Clara who writes Dear
John and Hank me and my best friend
share a notebook that we passed back and
forth and write in it was my turn with
the notebook and I was writing it on a
Greyhound bus wait Hank I forgot to ask
how you are
are you well oh sure whatever who cares
amidst your in the midst of a very
interesting event in your life that you
can't talk about yeah and like I am so
like proud and like unabashedly
internally proud of my ability to not be
like I'm working on a really cool thing
I can't tell you guys about like I don't
do that and I never will do that and I'm
upset that you made me just do it
well everybody on the internet is always
doing that and you do heroically avoid
it most of the time but I just forced
her hand you're you're really excited
about a thing you can't talk about let's
get back to Clara's question we called
it okay all right right so she was
writing in this on a Greyhound bus yeah
she shares a notebook with her best
friend when I got off the bus I realized
that the notebook was nowhere to be
found we called all the bus stops and
everywhere it could possibly be but we
still haven't found it
this notebook has all the details of our
entire lives for the last year I feel so
bad how do I tell my friend I lost it
notebooks and Diaries Clara uh yeah you
got have to get a new friend just this
one's over I'll like all the history
that you had together it doesn't even
exist anymore it's it's driving around
the country perpetually on a Greyhound
bus and you'll never you'll never you'll
never have it again it's gone by the way
I think this is a beautiful premise for
a novel I and I think it's a writ but I
actually have unlike you properly
helpful advice in the form of a personal
anecdote okay uh well maybe it'll help
me to to find the the laptop that I left
on a flight to freaking Amsterdam that
KLM never found so Hank I was recently
on a flight back from Venice Italy on
Delta my beloved Delta as you know I
have a long-term relationship with an
airline that airline is Delta I am
patiently waiting for them to sponsor me
but so far all ours
all my love has gotten me is a lot of
money spent on Delta anyway and I have
this hat that I always wear to the Indy
500 it is an Indy car hat it is a very
important part of my life I love the Hat
it's the Hat I feel most comfortable in
when I'm in public because it's very
hard to recognize me in the Hat and I
just I love the Hat it makes me happy
and I left the Hat in the airport lounge
in Venice Italy and then got on a plane
and the moment I like the moment the
plane took off I leaned forward to Sara
and I said oh my god I left my hat in
the airport lounge what are we gonna do
and Sara was like just contact Delta
they'll be fine they'll be cool about it
so I did and they were I mean like on
the plane
I used the wireless flying over the
Atlantic Ocean because of course Delta
has amazing wireless India and they they
were very helpful they were like we're
talking to the people in the lounge
we're gonna deal with this don't panic
it's gonna be okay and I was like I know
it's just a hat but it's incredibly
important hat is as important to me as
Clara's notebook presumably is to her
and this is what happened Hank
by the end of the flight they were like
we are concerned because we have looked
everywhere in the lounge and not found
it and that was upsetting to me yeah and
then I got off the plane like when we
landed the plane it was deep laning and
so I stood up and gathered all of my
things and realized that I had been
sitting on my hat all God
wow you're insufferable I didn't even
see that plot twist coming John oh my
god that's terrible
I'm ashamed to be your brother long
story short Farah have you looked in
your backpack III could I encourage you
to continue looking I have literally
right next to me on my bookshelf a
collection of notes that I sent that
were sent to me and we sent notes back
and forth in high school and I have them
right here still have them and sometimes
I do take them out and look at them and
they still kind of smell like high
school to me and and I do treasure those
memories and it is a shame Thank You
Clara feel better at all your maybe you
feel worse I well I I'm not going to
tell you that it's not like it is a it
is it is a it is a terrible thing to
lose things but I've also I lost a
computer that had a bunch of baby
pictures on it for my baby that I'll
never let presumably never get back and
and that is like it sucks and but you
can be okay and you can build all those
new memories again from scratch not
really though you really can't build
them again here's the thing Clara it's
this sucks but I also think it is an
opportunity for a new creative
enterprise where you guys try to
recreate the the previous notebook while
also creating a new notebook together
both try to recreate your old memories
and you try to make new memories that's
my best advice it is a bad situation but
you are not a bad person
and I think that your friend will
understand even though initially she
will be bummed out and somewhere on a
Greyhound bus somebody is like I can't
believe all of the zany adventures that
Clara and her best friend have gotten up
to I feel like we're not super oh well
this question guys by the way if you're
on if you're on a Greyhound bus listen
to this right now notice how his diary
get in touch with us because we have her
email address okay I'll do another
question this question comes from Emma
who asks dear Hank and John I've just
been invited to a good friends cat's
birthday party but I have no idea of the
proper etiquette for cat birthday
parties what do you do what do you get
for the cat is there a gift uh Hank I
understand you have a cat what do you do
for its birthday help kind of crazy for
cats
Emma John I don't know what my cat's
birthday is because it's a cat I can
finish that sentence for you it's a cat
knows their cat's birthday that's it's a
kid it's not like a dog I mean oh my god
Wow first of all you make like the Delta
representatives life of fricking
nightmare searching for your hat in the
stupid Delta lounge and now you are
offending not just me but every cat
person
what are you making it so hard to be
your brother I'm kidding of course every
cat owner knows their cat's birthday and
has cat birthday parties because that is
a totally normal thing to do in the
course of a regular human life yes yes I
mean so I've never been cami has never
had a cat birthday because we she's a
stray and we got her you know when she
was an adult cat so we don't know what
her birthday was but I definitely like
like if you want to get you the cat a
gift you're probably gonna want to talk
to talk to the owner about what kind of
cat get and I think that would be cute
like I don't think that there is any
expectation that you will get this cat a
gift
but it might be a nice fun thing to do
and if you want to be like what's your
cat's favorite kind of toy or what's he
cat favorite kind of treat I was just
happened to be next to Pet Smart and I
was thinking maybe I would get get it
something for its cat birthday but this
is just an opportunity for your friends
to hang out like that's all it is
this is a celebration of friendship and
a cat and so just go and have a good
time and don't worry too much about the
etiquette Hank I have to ask this very
important question okay it's from NAT
who writes dear brothers green recently
I had one of those moments where I was
suddenly confused by a phrase that I've
heard a lot but never properly thought
about what do we mean when we say
something can be seen from space when
talking about the Great Wall of China or
the pyramids we sometimes hear that they
are visible from space but we're in
space does that mean from the ISS if so
with the naked eye or with a big
telephoto lens photos on Google Earth
are taken from space but they can show
like license plates
thanks preemptively for helping these
make sense of this net yeah so yes there
are definitely places in space where you
can't even see the earth like the
majority the vast majority almost all of
space the whole earth is Sun isn't
visible the Milky Way galaxy is
invisible point Hank so that's it that's
a good point but where does space start
is there's a there's a place it's a
hundred kilometers up we've defined it
arbitrarily it's called the Carmen line
so I guess it means if you could see it
from the Carmen line Rob dinner you can
see it from space and I don't know how
high the ISS is but it's not super high
so that's sort of like generally also
like where the Space Shuttle is where
the ISS is if you can see it from there
that's mostly what the talking about cuz
that's where most of the eyeballs have
been in space is is that the ISS
speaking of which by the way according
to the internet the Great Wall of China
is just barely visible from low-earth
orbit and cannot be seen from the moon
but many man-made objects can be seen
clearly from low-earth orbit without
magnification including some dams and
city lights and stuff yeah yeah it is
interesting that the the Great Wall of
China for a long time was thought to be
the only object you could see from space
that was made by man but then it turned
out that you couldn't really see it and
there were a bunch of others that you
could
right for instance you can see the
Bingham Canyon Mine and oh sure man yeah
that's a that's a big I wouldn't
necessarily call that a structure so
much as a the opposite of a structure
it's a wholly structured yeah there's
some pretty big holes John we have made
some pretty big holes I mean if there's
one thing that human beings are good at
it is moving earth yeah yeah do you want
to know I don't know where I have told
this story I think I made a youtube
video about it once that yeah that's
what it was there was a there was a test
question and it was like a geography
test for maybe elementary school and it
said what is the most powerful force on
earth and I think that the teacher was
looking for maybe water which which
shapes a great deal of the surface of
the earth but the person had the student
had written love hmm which I then went
on to argue that probably in fact love
being the thing that has created so many
humans in a both a metaphorical and a
rather physical sense that maybe love is
the most powerful force on earth
considering how fast people are
affecting it this question comes from
Julio who asks dear Hank and John I have
a question for you brought all the way
from Guatemala by the magic of the
internet I'm taking a medicine that is
only applied on the skin and my body
absorbs it I don't have to take any
actual medicine or put it anywhere
inside my body just on the skin and that
made me wonder if I stick my arm into a
jar of orange juice well I get all the
vitamin C I need thank you arm in orange
juice Julio oh that's a great question
Hank can I avoid scurvy just by sticking
my arm in a giant vat of orange juice I
don't know I bet you you definitely
could if you like stuck your eyeballs
into it it's on second thought it's not
a great idea if I like opened up my eyes
inside a gigantic pool of orange juice
and just let the vitamin C seep in yeah
you'd probably get enough vitamin C
doing that I don't know if you'd absorb
enough of it through your skin there's
different kinds of compounds that absorb
more readily through the skin and I
don't know if vitamin C I think it's
ascorbic acid
probably wouldn't be one of those but
but you know anything is gonna go
through to some in some small amount
wait are you saying that the skin is
like a toad I was thinking about this
because I used to wear a Nick Nick Atene
patch back in the back in the days when
I was trying to quit smoking before I
discovered the magic of nicorette and
went on to chew Nicorette for seven long
years before finally quitting Nicorette
anyway I was about this tall that
happened before vaping John and you
didn't have to do that instead that's
true that's true
so I was thinking about it because the
idea that my skin is not an impermeable
sort of structure that protects me from
the world is deeply upsetting to me like
there's something horrifying about
knowing that like medicine can seep in
through my skin because that means other
things can too yeah I mean it does seem
like there's this definite barrier
between the outside and the inside and
your skin is considered by some to be
the largest and most important organ in
your immune system it is like obviously
without your skin there's you are much
more prone to infection but you know
molecules are very small they're much
smaller than bacteria for example and I
you know ascorbic acid is a very small
molecule but there are certain things
like how hydrophobic something is or how
hydrophilic something is that can affect
how easily and and also how big how
large the molecule is that can affect
how easily it goes through the skin but
that that's the nice thing is to
remember that like the size of a
molecule and the size of a bacteria are
on completely different scales so like
having a like a poison or a medicine go
into your body through your skin is very
different from having some like foreign
invader to it which really does need a
[ __ ] in the armor there so you're
saying that my skin will at least keep
the bacteria away from my body even
though if my but my body is still
crawling with bacteria literally and
figuratively yeah on all the parts that
are covered in skin
yes great wonderful thanks for reminding
me about all the parts that aren't
covered in skin hey before we get to
another question from our listeners we
have to quickly pause to say that we
have received the most extraordinary
email response I think we've ever
received in the history of this program
it came from Bree who wrote Dear John
and Hank recently a person named Bree
sent in a question with a sign-off that
was something to the effect of
completely lacking a sign off as a Bree
I just want to let this Bree and all
breeze out there know that there is a
best sign-off for us it is float like a
butterfly sting like a Brie hope this
helps float like a butterfly sting like
a Brie good holy God Hank oh man that's
good we cannot believe that I missed the
opportunity to name Alice Bree I am yeah
well I am grits like brie is a good one
that there are opportunities there like
there are you know there are there are
brie rhymes but I'm wondering like how
many like names specific sign offs we
can get I wouldn't mind if we had a
section on next week's podcast that were
like that but with other names right
this week a name specific sign offs yes
exact that's a great idea
so a few so we're at at Hank and John a
gmail.com if you have anything occur to
you that you would like to send to us to
share because I really do like this
trend this does the idea of it I want
and I want a name specific sign-off and
I don't have a good one
sometimes when people ask me how I spell
my name I always say green like the
color John like the Baptist and
something but it's not as good as a name
specific sign-off no yeah all right
what's our next question comes from
Cassidy who asks dear Hank and John I
was drinking a glass of wine tonight and
I soon notice that a tiny little bug guy
was swimming around in the glass which
is mostly just rude but I'm sure he
didn't intend to ruin my drink my
question is do bugs get drunk or rather
what does alcohol do to
is it like the best day of their short
lives or are they totally unaffected
please help me because I would like to
know if that bug was numbed at all when
I poured him down the drain bugs and
booze Cassady yes yes that is my guess
my guess is that bugs do get drunk bugs
do get drunk they've done some research
on this the they did some bee research
where they exposed bees to ethanol and
and saw that their behavior was affected
it wasn't necessarily the kind of things
you might expect like they weren't like
extra gregarious or they just did less
mostly they did less of everything just
lazy romance but yeah so it does appear
that bugs get drunk and probably so
these bees were exposed to like 2.5
percent ethanol which is a lot less than
is in wine so there's a really good
chance that your fly was pretty wasted
by the time he hit the drain so you
might not have even be able to serve who
have survived that level of alcohol
poisoning so you basically get you know
did him a favor
except that probably he just died of
alcohol poisoning in the drain it's not
like just being inside of a drain
immediately kills you unless there's a
garbage disposal down there I don't know
how you did it what a way to go just
died of alcohol poisoning in the drain
of Cassidy's sink what a what a good
life
yeah that's how we should all be so
lucky Hank has to die like that bug did
oh no I want to I want to die not in a
train and not of alcohol poisoning those
are - those are my two requests today oh
man I've got so many more requests for
how I don't want to die I've got it
sometime I should introduce you into my
top ten list of how I don't want to die
except that I know that if I do that I'm
too superstitious because I know that if
I do that that I'm gonna be stuck with
one of those deaths and then when like
the Indianapolis Star publishes my
obituary they'll be like he died you
know in a drain of alcohol poisoning
just as he begged not to in episode 108
of dear Hank and John yeah I did
actually recently read a story that was
exactly that like the person who said
that they didn't want to die in a
certain way to
and they died that way at that age and
it ya know yeah huh I'm gonna say it
again in the hopes that I can bend the
universe to my will I want my last words
to be this sure has been an amazing 145
years of perfect health alright Hank
this next question comes from Ryan who
writes dear John and Hank when I was a
kid I was made to be ashamed of liking
so-called girly stuff I've always been
big and tall and masculine and I've
lived with the expectations that apply
to so many men growing up in the 1980s
and 1990s the thing is I've been able to
abandon most of my preconceptions and
ignorance over time and I've worked hard
to provide a judgment-free environment
for my son in this regard but I can't
get past my own shame for liking girly
music I don't even believe in the idea
of girly so why is it that when I'm
blasting Melanie Martinez in my car I
turned the volume down at stop why am i
afraid of something that I know doesn't
exist
am i hopelessly doomed to live with the
ghosts of homophobia any help would be
appreciated still trying to figure this
part out Ryan
PS love the show you guys have played a
big part of my region I'm very grateful
give a hug to all the folks who worked
behind the scenes for me thanks again
and sorry for lying about my name Ryan
you're better than that
you're better than that rock that's very
nice nice little message there that's
very sweet to think about all the people
who work behind the scenes that's very
nice I also want to say that why am i
afraid of something that I know doesn't
exist is one of the great questions we
have ever been asked and I do not think
we will be able to approach an answer
today Ryan but that is a beautiful
question that I would not mind having
tattooed on the inside of my wrist yeah
pulling up at a stoplight is a really
weird interaction where you like know
the person next to you is like there and
they know you're there but you're in
your own sort of separate private box
spaces and I feel like sort of separate
like sort of different about it when I'm
on a bike if I'm on a bike and I pull up
next to a car at a stoplight I'm kind of
like hey I'm basically in your car now
like I'm just standing here next to your
car and your window is open and so it's
like kind of weird for me not to
recognize
that you're there but if I'm in a car
like we're in our own worlds and if like
my like world starts to encroach on your
world I feel kind of weird about it and
I used to do this intentionally I used
to like like like sing really loud or
like play drums loud on the dashboard so
that the people in the car next to me
would see me and I could like perform
for them a little bit cuz John I don't
know if you know this but I'm a little
bit like the attention and as a younger
man liked it more than I even do now
very true deeply true i I think that
when you're pulling up to a stoplight
you're afraid of somebody you're afraid
of a stranger's judgement but I turned
down I always think like oh I'm gonna
keep listening to this music really
loudly because I want people to know
what good taste in music I have but when
the moment actually comes I always find
myself turning down the music
even if I'm super pleased with it
because I don't want to make it weird
for them I don't want to make like their
car trip about me so maybe maybe that's
what you're doing rather than turning it
down just out of fear of judgement maybe
there's also an element of I don't want
to make this other person's right I'm in
their car about what music I'm listening
like the opposite of what I was doing
which was very much like I am now going
to make your private moment about me
look at my car person which I think
maybe is not the worst thing to do
because for the most part people are
alone in their cars and maybe they're
having some good thoughts but but maybe
just have a little bit of a thing for
them to experience and be like I saw
this dumb child driving a Volvo 240
today and they can tell their family
about it alright but I'm totally in
favor of of the the the sort of
adrenaline rush of jumping into like
really loving something in front of a
stranger and I and and that's always
going to be a little bit scary but I
think that it is something that I would
like to see more of I would like to see
more people loving things in front of me
and so like I mean that's that that is
of that can be taken out of context so
much easier than what you said about
book burning and it's so much more
disturbing I'm so bad at interviews like
oh my god yeah Wow I to get to the
question though I mean I think that I
mean to get to the heart of the question
it it takes a long time to get to get
past notions that you grow up with like
it takes a really like I was told when I
was a kid that I was girly because I
liked reading the baby-sitters club and
I still feel like the baby-sitters club
was for girls even though I liked it
it's really really hard to get past
those entrenched notions that the
culture gives you because they're so
powerful and you're right that they're
not really real but they also are real
because even though they're constructed
they're still real and they're powerful
but I think being conscious of it is a
huge like that's the big first step and
then the second step is slowly
dismantling it over time within within
yourself you know but it's it's work and
it takes time I think this podcast of
course it's a good time to mention is
brought to you by slowly dismantling
cultural preconceptions over time inside
yourself slowly dismantling cultural
preconceptions within yourself hard
time-consuming but recommended it would
be great if ideas like that Hank could
actually sponsor podcasts maybe in the
future today's podcast is also brought
to you by Kat birthdays Kat birthdays
John supports them and he apologizes for
whatever he said that offended cat
people
I love cat people and please buy Turtles
all the way down available at probably
sign Turtles calm right now this podcast
additionally is brought to you by
quivering doves quivering doves
apparently they give live birth I got
that line from my friend MT Anderson and
I don't know when he says it it's it's
so extremely compelling but then when I
say it I just sounds kind of like a
doofus
if it was like Emily Dickinson or
something I was so lovely I know well
that's that's how that's how empty
Anderson speaks he speaks constantly as
if he is inside of an Emily Dickinson
poem he's one of the most eloquent
people I have ever encountered Hank yes
we also have an actual sponsor today we
do its hover hover and I wanted to ask
you if you remember your first ever like
website that was yours your first ever
personal site um I mean I had so back in
the day it was much harder to get domain
names and so my first thing was was on
the the what was it called back when
back before AOL existed even I'm guess I
ll existant but there were like there
were local companies that provided
access to the Internet and so we had one
of those and like they let you like put
stuff on their server at like it was ia
Ginette it was the internet access group
was the one in Orlando and and then they
like how to like like slash and then
there was you could put in your own
little name there and that is where I
had my Mars web site when I first had my
Mars web site it was like I Aegina slash
tilde CRS which was our dad's user name
slash Mars was where I had my first it
was a great website I remember it was
devoted to the idea that we should
explore Mars and people took you totally
seriously even though you were like a 13
year old
well that was which is one of the
magical things about the Internet to me
is that it has that great democratizing
force I also had a website where I wrote
like on that server where I wrote like
little pieces humor pieces I guess and
it was called Johnny saw me naked
I remember Johnny saw me naked uh yeah
so anyway we bring that up because hover
does for people and for the Internet
what we had in our first websites way
back in the day it lets you create a
space that's for you and that isn't
controlled by any other social media but
that is reflective of you and you can
use any of the classic domain
because now you don't have to use I AG
net you can use any camor net or they've
also got you know everything from dot
design to dot pizza if you uh if you use
our promo code you can get 10% off of
your first hover purchase by going
either to hover comm slash Dear John or
presumably to hover comm / something
else but we don't have to talk about
that at hover.com slash dear Hank you
can find your own place that's your
place that you control that you know
find your domain name that is what you
want it to be and isn't one of the many
things that is kind of weirdly I feel
like controlled externally and I really
like having a hankering calm having a
place where it's me and mine and and I
can I can I can always know that I can
control that and that can be mine if I
need it that's right
alright so thank you to hover comm for
sponsoring today's video again that's
hover.com slash Dear John that is the
best way to get 10% off your first
purchase and find a domain that names
your passion
alright let's answer one more question
from our listeners I this we've got to
get to this one it's important this
question comes from Alejandro who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a
seventeen-year-old undocumented
immigrant in need of dubious advice last
week I lost my job for the second time
this year due to my legal status I
dropped out of my high school at the end
of my junior year because my parents
wanted me out of the house by the end of
the summer which is fast approaching
today I found out my daca application
was denied and I am headed to the
hospital to check on my 16 year old
brother who has leukemia in short my
life is a mess I'm also a photographer
and I'm rather successful in the small
city I live in Photography is my passion
and I surround myself with creative
individuals who share the same interest
as I do my life outside of work and home
is enjoyable but my problems in life
seemed to surround two very specific
parts of Who I am I'm gay which is why
my parents are kicking me out of the
house and I'm an immigrant which is why
I can't hold onto a job for more than a
couple months my question is how can I
feel like I'm more than that I know that
being gay in an immigrant or
of challenges in my life I will learn
from but my life revolves so heavily
around these two topics that I can't
help but feel that they are all that I
am any dubious advices appreciated dum
spiro spero Alejandro I so I felt pretty
unqualified to answer this question so I
reached out to my friend Julien who is
an undocumented immigrant and but has
his his daca and he had a lot of really
smart and interesting things to say one
of course is just in general to be
informed about your status as an
immigrant in America and there's website
at informed immigrant calm which is a
good place to go and and I may send I
may send Alejandro Julian's whole
response which is very nice and long and
detailed and also includes stuff about
how like there are ways to work in
America especially if you are you know
somebody's successful in a creative
endeavor like photography if you start
your own LLC then there are
opportunities for you to basically work
for yourself legally but I think that
this is this is a really wonderful point
about identity that like when something
is affecting you negatively a like
statuses that you have or identities
that you have they can sort of take over
who you are and and sometimes that's
really uncomfortable and you just don't
want that and my advice and also
Julian's advice is to look for other
identities that you can you know and
like not to say that you like shouldn't
be proud and and and excited and love
these parts of your identity but also
look at your other identities like your
identity as a photographer and your
identity as you know a fan of you know I
assume of this podcast or other things
that you love and look for communities
where that surround themselves with you
know with those kinds of things yeah I
think that's all really good advice I
think the main reason I wanted to share
this question is to remind people who
aren't going through this experience
that there are lots of people in the
u.s. who are and that their lives are
valuable and we are lucky to have them
in this country and yeah that is all
thank you John and Thank You Alejandra
for writing in and and best of luck and
I'll get you in touch with Julie and he
has some good thoughts and ideas that
that hopefully will be helpful and he
suggested he asked me to get the two of
you in touch this next and I think last
question comes from Natalie who asks
dear Hank and John I was making toaster
waffles just now and when they were
finished I sat down to eat my meal with
the mess still laid out on the counter
my brother came back and made himself
some waffles then he left everything out
and never came back to clean up the mess
who should have to clean it up the
person who first made the mess or the
person who was last with the waffles
keep in mind
Petie sibling feuds are a real thing so
compromise probably isn't an option
Natalie well Hank I think we're both
going to have the same answer to this
question and so it's not going to be a
really interesting debate but the answer
of course is that we don't have enough
information to answer the question
because we don't know if Natalie is an
older sibling or a younger sibling and
the answer is that the younger sibling
has to clean up the waffle crap I mean I
so I've shared this question with with
Katherine last night and she said to me
I'll tell you who doesn't clean up the
mess is your mom so don't you dare let
this get in the way of like your mom
still after all these years having to
deal with your bull that's right now to
just figure that's right Natalie figure
it out don't make your parents do it
that's the only thing we're sure of no I
think that the person who last used the
waffles has to clean it up although I
would also feel that I would wonder now
see like well I didn't you clean it up
in the first place thereby preventing
your brother from using waffles at all
that would have been really brilliant I
do like I have this thing and I think
it's I can't be the only one where like
I've left out some stuff and then
someone else comes in and uses it and
I'm like yeah that's no longer my
responsibility yeah you would have got
that stuff out anyway and made that mess
so now this just worked out perfectly
for me yeah I totally agree
that's settled so no it is not settled
Hank what the AFC Wimbledon situation
mmm what so it's not good it's not good
oh very bad it's been a very bad start
to the season two games played one goal
one point now that is enough to
currently have kept AFC Wimbledon out of
the relegation zone because there are
one two three four five teams that have
played - and lost - one of whom is the
franchise currently applying its trade
in Milton Keynes so I guess that's good
news
however the Dons lost to Shrewsbury over
the weekend and it was by all accounts
not a particularly inspiring performance
I was not able to watch it because I
have not gotten the video thing that
that you can now sign on for to work but
I will give you an update when I do get
it to work I've heard that it's working
for other people so that's good but yeah
it was not a good game by all accounts
Shrewsbury almost scored a number of
times but goalkeeper George long did a
good job of keeping the ball out of the
net except for that one time and it was
a one-nil draw I think of greater
concern is the fact that if you count
wait what's a one nil draw I'm sorry of
one no loss I was paying attention no
loss good job paying attention I was
testing you
I think I'm greater concern going into
the rest of the season is that if you go
back to last season I think in the last
800 or so minutes of Ligue 1 action for
AFC Wimbledon we've scored just the once
which is not a great it's not great it's
not great so hopefully things yeah they
like shrink down the goal or something
like what's happened is Lyle Taylor's
foot fall off is there a third issue
well we lost arguably our best striker
from last season Tom Elliot I don't know
it's hard to know while Taylor came on
as a substitute in the game against
Shrewsbury and did have a
pretty positive impact it sounds like
but a goal it's hard to score goals in
soccer but it shouldn't be this hard so
yeah that's the update what's the news
from Mars the news from Mars is that
there is a mission that has been hanging
out and around Mars occasionally taking
little dips into the upper atmosphere
called maven the MAVEN spacecraft and it
is about to take another dip so as we
discussed
oddly enough earlier in this episode
there is sort of a point at which at
which space begins and atmosphere ends
and that's a fuzzy point like it doesn't
just happen like it there that that sort
of there's a gradient of atmosphere
thinning out for a long long way and so
maven is gonna drop down to I think 125
kilometers above or maybe 150 kilometers
above the surface of Mars no 125 so
basically just above what would on earth
be the Karman line and and it sucks up
little pieces of gas and part of what it
has done and been really effective at
doing is understanding the process by
which Mars went from a pretty nice place
on the edge of the habitable zone of our
star to you know a place without
atmosphere without water on the surface
except for some ice and and that
happened when when Mars is magnetic
field shut down early in its history and
after that happened maven has been
really effective in understanding how
like kind of devastating the sun's solar
wind has been to the planet Mars and to
sort of it's like potential habitability
because since that magnetic field shut
down the Sun has been really good at
just pushing off any gas around Mars
into the you know interplanetary space
and maven is been doing this research
for a long time and it's about to take
another dip to learn a little bit more
this is gonna be its closest that it
will have gotten to the planet and they
want to save these observations for
later because as it gets closer to the
planet it hits more gas part
and that slows it down and eventually we
won't have enough fuel to get back up to
higher more stable orbit so maven still
doing its job and we're understanding a
lot more about how ridiculously
important Earth's magnetic field is yeah
I'm strong I'm as you talked about that
becoming more and more in favor of
Earth's magnetic field and also a little
nervous about its suddenly disappearing
is there any thought that that might
happen ah no no so I have two good could
two good pieces of news on that front
one it would take a long time for
Earth's magnetic field to shut down and
there would be a lot of changes in signs
that it would be happening so it's a
long way off if it is ever a thing
second there's actually been some really
interesting research lately and I'm
working on a scishow episode about this
right now about creating an artificial
magnetic field potentially for Mars and
also potentially for interplanetary
spacecraft the idea being if you put
sort of an object pretty far away that
disrupts the solar wind it doesn't
necessarily have to have it doesn't have
to be that it doesn't necessarily have
to be that huge of a magnetic field
generator to sort of deflect those
particles so that they won't end up
hitting Earth which would also be a
great thing to have because our magnetic
field protects us from the vast majority
of solar high-energy particles but when
there's a large flare it can have
negative impacts on earth so that could
be a potential kind of failsafe for to
protect ourselves and and I'm super into
the idea of protecting ourselves from
that here on earth also when were
traveling between planets where you
don't have any protection at all and
also when we're on the surface of other
planets that don't have magnetic fields
I mean I can't wait for the future I
know that I'm not gonna be around for
any of this like the crazy intergalactic
future we don't have an intergalactic
future but the crazy interstellar future
yeah well I dream to have any that it's
going to happen you think that if we can
just make it through the next 200 years
we will have an interstellar future Wow
that's that's a cool thought I mean I
think that we will I think that we will
explore interstellar like we all have
interstellar exploration it is very hard
and of course a science fiction has
dealt with this in auditor entwisted
it's hard for me to imagine getting
humans to another star it's just it's
said that is an engineering feat but
maybe maybe I don't know man
I mean who among us would have guessed
that we would have a incredibly reliable
Toyota Corolla you know that's true I
mean just at this point I'm reaching out
for any sponsorship opportunity I can
find a free Toyota Corolla
oh I mean John but we've got hover so he
can't say you can't say nothing we got
we got it going on we got / deer think
boar hover.com / Dear John Hank thank
you for potting with me you can email us
by the way at Hank and John at gmail.com
or you can find us on Twitter I'm John
Green Hank is Hank green I got I don't
like Twitter much these days but I do go
on there yeah yeah I do too
and if you've got good sign-offs buzz
name specific sign ups would be very
interested in seeing those if you got
any for John specifically apparently
he's in dire need this podcast is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
our social media and community manager
is Victoria bon giorno where you can
find out more about what she's up to at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John and
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
you
[Music]